y'all need to respect the chaos King  check this out so the chaos King is  immune to aging and death he has the  ability to manipulate and change reality  at will including the Realms of cosmic  entities he possesses immense physical  strength and durability that exceeds any  and all Cosmic entities he can  manipulate and control energy to a  Godlike level he has the ability to  manipulate the fundamental nature of  matter he can control the minds of  cosmic entities he can manipulate time  and travel through it he has the ability  to create illusions that can trick  Cosmic entities and he can manipulate  and travel through different dimensions  even the dimensions of cosmic entities  themselves and he can drain energy and  power from any and all beings in  existence make sure you guys follow for  more